(banjo music)
(phone ringing)
- [Mother On Phone]
Hi honey, how are you?
- I don't know, things
aren't going well.
- [Mother] They're not?
- No.
- [Mother] What happened?
- I'm on the Tennessee River.
- [Mother] Well how did you get
on the Tennessee
River, I thought you
were supposed to be
on the Mississippi?
- Apparently Mississippi
was too dangerous,
so now we got to the Tennessee
River and it looks like--
- [Mother] I know,
there's supposed to be
really, really bad
weather like flooding,
and tornadoes, you've
got to get out of there.
- I do have to get out
of there, thanks mom.
I love you.
- [Mother On Phone] Alright,
well, love you baby, bye--
- We gotta get out of here!
(jet ski revving)
- The Mississippi was
running hard and high.
Storms can get really rough.
You notice we never saw
any other pleasure boats
on that river at all.
Dead bodies, everything,
I mean, you know,
it's just the, it's the
nation's sewer system,
you might see a dead
cow floating by.
I mean you know, the people
that live on the river
just roll their trash down
the hill and in the river.
I mean God only knows
how many stolen cars
are on the bottom of
that river somewhere.
(dubstep music)
(banjo music)
- Li'l Minnow.
- Yes?
- How many goats have we
sent to Africa so far?
- 173 goats.
- I gotta inspire people,
what gets people money?
- Gangs.
- Gangs?
I got an idea, throw me a phone.
Throw me another phone.
Kyle, it's Kurt.
- [Kyle] Hey, what's up?
- How you doing, man?
- [Kyle] I'm doing great
man, just being dry.
- Listen, I'm thinking about
starting a jet ski gang,
I was wondering if you're busy.
- [Kyle] Well yeah but
do it buddy, let's do it.
- I'll see ya soon, buddy.
Let's do this shit.
(jet ski revving)
- God I love that man.
- So we start a jet ski gang,
we're called the Wet Ones.
We had little pleather
vests that we would wear.
- [Jet Ski Riders] Live
free and die moist!
(Spanish music)
- [Kurt On Stage]
Boom, just like that,
I had my very own jet ski gang.
- [Kurt] Wet Ones are
mopping up hunger!
- [Kurt On Stage] And
very quickly, I realized
I had no idea what
to do with them.
- [Kurt] What does
a jet ski gang do?
- I think we gotta do
a brunch comedy show.
- If there's nothing
I don't like more,
it's 11:00 a.m.
stand-up comedy show.
- You don't wanna
hit 'em at noon,
they're picking out their
food, by one they're full.
- Let's do an 11:00 a.m.
stand-up comedy show,
in the middle of Lake Pickwick.
- [Kurt On Stage] So of course,
we headed to the first
biker bar we could find,
because I'm sure we'd
totally fit in there.
Now, this place Freddy T's
is kinda like if you took
an Applebee's, and
then crammed it inside
a teen dance club from Miami,
and then filled it with bikers
and then put it in the
middle of Tennessee.
It is a real fucked up place.
- I think before
they start the show
they oughta take a moment,
and thank all the veterans
in the United States of America,
because if we didn't have
these freedoms that we got now,
we'd be in a communist
motherfucking country.
- And so the whole
audience is bikers,
and we're wearing
pleather vests,
made to make fun of bikers.
So it's a very difficult
situation we found ourselves in.
- I can't believe
you guys all aren't
at work right now, bike gang.
(audience laughter)
We got the gang out, we
got Big Bear, we got Earl.
We got Glitter Steve over there,
we got Sparkle Dave.
We got 'em all out.
We got Kissy Lips.
Did I get the names right,
or was I wrong on 'em?
Is everybody just nervous
or was it not funny?
(audience laughter)
I rode with the Dance
City Prancers for a while.
I got tickled into that gang.
You ever get tickled in?
You don't wanna see what
they do to get you out.
They just make you a big
cake, and they wish ya well.
What's that?
Don't come out gay.
What's gonna give it away,
this plastic vest I'm wearing?
There's a guy wearing the
same thing over there.
Just don't be gay,
let's all wear
the same leather colors together
and ride our
motorbikes around town.
(audience laughter)
Hey, it's all just
pink engine parts
when you get down to
it, what does it matter?
Who cares, I've been watching
a lot of gay porn lately.
I'm not gay, but I watch it,
because I want to be
objective you know?
Like I'll watch it after
the stuff I like to watch,
because that's when
I can be open minded,
like once I get my demons out.
Click over, see what the
fellas are up to, you know?
It's way tougher than any
sport you can possibly like,
is two dudes banging each other.
It is way, way more tough.
Imagine watching
football where everybody
on the field got along.
There's nothing to be
scared of, it's two dudes,
doing MMA the right way.
(audience laughter)
If you're worried about your
dick wiggling there Big Bear
that's on you man,
I got no problem.
I'm picking on ya Big Bear,
I'm sorry, I didn't mean to.
Because you're the scariest one,
I'm going prison rules.
I'm not gonna punch ya, I'm
just gonna make jokes at ya,
and hope that everybody
gets on my side.
It's a matter of
respect right now.
(audience laughter)
This has been awesome,
get back out for Kurt.
- Kyle Kinane
everybody, give it up!
Thank you guys so
much for coming out,
let's get wet for goats!
I walked into that place,
thinking we're gonna die.
But Kyle won these
guys over in a way
that I never could have.
And then at the end of the show,
Kyle just gets on
the back of the bike
with this dude named Big Bear,
and they take off.
Hey I don't know, is he
going to the airport,
they're gonna go make meth
together, I don't know.
But Kyle Kinane is one of
the fucking good ones, man.
It was an amazing show.
Well here I go again on my own,
time to get back on the water.
What'd I do this morning?
Formed a jet ski gang,
and then we did a stand-up
show for a bunch of bikers
in one of the weirdest
bars I've ever been to.
We lost Kyle Kinane because
he became best friends
with a biker, but
that's how it goes
when you're on the
road, I don't judge him.
But I still got a job to do.
I gotta send 500 goats and
1000 chickens to Africa.
In order to do that, I gotta
make it 100 miles today.
Roustabout.
(dubstep music)
Hey, I risked my
life in a biker bar,
but you don't have to do that.
All you have to do
is click on this link
and donate to Heifer right now.
Come on, give 'em some money.
Bwah.